you know my expose on Vanderbilt's
gender Clinic continues to make major
waves in a in a major way on a national
and local level even as every effort is
made on the other side to lie deflect
change the subject or act like there's
nothing here worth talking about in the
first place uh Vanderbilt has the
advantage of a national and local media
that knows its role in a situation like
this that is to act as de facto PR
representatives for the institution for
example our local Nashville Public Radio
published an article written by a
Shameless hack named Blake farmer which
says the headline is this
Vanderbilt is the latest Target in a
far-right campaign against transgender
health clinics
that's the headline and this is
supposedly they position themselves as a
objective news Outlet the article itself
of course makes no specific mention of
any of the details I revealed in my
report except to say that I used
inflammatory language when describing
their practices
describing them accurately is
inflammatory meanwhile The Tennessean
which is another major local publication
tried to ignore the issue completely but
was eventually forced to acknowledge it
with this headline
Vanderbilt clarifies gender affirming
care policies amid conservative attacks
now National media hasn't been much
better The Daily Beast reported on the
situation with this framing Vanderbilt
Medical Clinic shuts down its website
after transphobic attacks
now the Washington Post was a little bit
more subtle with a fair headline social
media post Sparks calls to investigate
Tennessee's vumc which is fine then a
relatively even-handed report except
that the Post article like nearly every
other article written on the subject
from a non-conservative outlet does not
specifically mention the procedures that
the hospital performs on kids
the post says that I criticized
Vanderbilt for some of the quote
Services provided to minors but it does
not actually specify that those Services
include double mastectomies for 16 year
old girls irreversible hormone
treatments puberty blocking drugs that
are also used to chemically castrate sex
offenders
um the post will not include those
details because it knows that nearly
everyone who reads it will recoil in
revulsion and horror and say to
themselves you're telling me that's not
already illegal
I should also note here that the
progressive Christian Community in
Nashville otherwise known as you know
Heretics have taken a special interest
in this case and are rallying around the
hospital Matthew Paul Turner is a
Christian children's book author who
came out as gay a few years ago and then
left his wife and children and he
tweeted you're a terrible human Matt
Walsh
you make nothing better and one day your
sad little existence will reap what it
has sown over and over again
now that last part sounds almost like a
threat though uh I can't say I'm too
concerned but it is a little
disappointing in another way that that
you know again this is a children's book
author his name is also Matthew and
somehow we can't stick together
maybe he's just upset that my book sold
more in a week than probably his entire
catalog has sold in a lifetime but
anyway also uh Robin Henderson Espinoza
is a self-described activist Theologian
and clergy member who's preferred
pronouns are I'm not making this up
he they and doctor
so doctor has been listed as preferred
pronoun unironically
Robin tweeted this is white Christian
nationalist terrorizing children as a
trans person and clergy member I stand
with the underside of History not those
using the underside for their political
gain
I have no doubt that Robin is focused on
the underside I however am focused on
protecting children and protecting them
from horrific sexual and physical abuse
and medical experimentation
and in order to do that to really
protect them action
must be taken let me ask you something
here's a question I've asked you yet
what if there was someone out there who
kept a log of every single thing you did
every minute of the day I think we'd
agree that'd be pretty creepy well what
if I told you that's exactly what
happens every time you go online your
internet provider like at T or comcast
is allowed to store logs of every
website you've ever visited they can
legally sell this data to anybody that
they want that's why I always use
expressvpn expressvpn reroutes your
internet connection through your their
secure servers so your internet provider
can't see or log what you do online now
many of you might be wondering well if
I'm routing all my data through a VPN
then doesn't that mean that the VPN can
see what I'm doing and they can log my
data instead well you're right to think
that many vpns claim to have a no logs
policy but they've been caught login
customer activity anyway that's why
expressvpn is the only VPN I trust
because they use trusted server
technology they were the first to
provide to first major VPN provider to
engineer all of their VPN servers to run
in Ram this makes it impossible for
their VPN servers to store any data
including logs of the expressvpn
customer stop letting people keep logs
of what you do online visit
expressvpn.com Matt walshow right now
and find out how you can get three
months free you know on the right we
have been historically I think pretty
good at identifying important issues and
raising awareness about them and that
needs to happen the the rareness the the
awareness raising the Consciousness
raising needs to happen it's important
because most people you know when it
comes to this issue
didn't know that this was happening to
kids and would have probably assumed
that it was already illegal
no change can be made culturally until
you reach a critical mass of people who
recognize that there is a problem and uh
and and that there is something that
must be changed and understand why it
must be changed so on the issue of
gender ideology we've been working to
build to that critical mass but what
happens when you get there
see this is where the right again
judging historically typically falters
because we tell every everyone that
something bad is happening and then lots
of people respond wow that's bad thanks
for telling me
and then we say well great talk folks
and we move on
the bad thing still fully intact
you know it's the bad things still
happening
so converting attention into action
that is where we fail
the left is very good at that
the right historically has been very bad
but not this time
we are going to do something about this
now I've already personally met with two
high-ranking members of the Tennessee
House and Senate and we are working on a
bill together that would ban all gender
transition procedures for minors in the
state no drugs no surgeries
we are going to shut down Vanderbilt's
pediatric gender clinic and we're going
to make sure that no one else opens one
in this state ever again
we're also moving on the federal level
I've been in conversation with Senator
Marsha Blackburn who hosted a screening
of my film what is a woman a few weeks
ago and there were many local lawmakers
by the way who attended that screening
and I've been told personally that by
some of them that this movie has
motivated them to move against gender
ideology in the state I heard the same
thing from some of those politicians
that I hear from average people on the
street which is again I didn't know this
was happening you know or or I didn't
know it was this bad
now they know following our report on
Vanderbilt Marshall Blackburn has now
issued a letter to the FDA calling for
an investigation into puberty blockers
which have never been approved for use
on children in this way in fact the very
concept of a puberty blocker has never
been sufficiently studied or
investigated at all the drugs are used
off label for the purpose of blocking
puberty and there has been no effort in
the medical community to really
understand the long-term or even
short-term effects of this usage
so getting the FDA involved is an
important First Step I've also been in
communication with representative
Marjorie Taylor green who introduced a
bill weeks ago Banning child gender
transitions on the federal level
now right now no bill like that can
actually be passed into law of course
but it's important to have them on the
table anyway just as the FDA might right
now
ignore Marcia Blackburn's demands but
it's important to make the demand anyway
and that's because we are forcing this
conversation we are making it an issue
the midterms are a few weeks from now
we have made sexual indoctrination of
children and medical child abuse
enormous National issues in the lead-up
to the election
that is not an accident
back in January I tweeted that I was
planning an all-out assault on gender
ideology this year and that it would
begin with a project that would change
the conversation around the topic in
June we released what is a woman which I
think and hope fulfilled that promise
and is still fulfilling it
several weeks ago I pledged on this show
that we would take the momentum that we
built from that film and we would turn
it into a national movement that would
lead to tangible results and real action
and that is beginning right now
Tennessee is just the start
most importantly
we are fully on the offense now
okay we're we're not waiting around
for the left to tell us what topics we
should discuss or what positions we
should adopt
as the right has for so long operated
the left tells us the topics we're going
to talk about and then they also tell us
what position we're going to take by you
know we just take whatever the opposite
position of them is and then so they are
setting the terms
okay but we're not doing that now we are
not scrambling to take defensive
postures all the time as the left
dictates the terms of the argument
we are talking about things they don't
want to talk about
and we are fighting a battle that they
desperately don't want to have to fight
and are not prepared to fight
so this time we are the ones with the
plan of action and they are the ones
scrambling to respond
you can tell that they're not used to
being in that position
and they don't like it
and that's how it should
because this is how we win
well before you go uh hit the Subscribe
button and ring the bell and while
you're at it if you want to go watch or
listen to my full show head to
dailywire.com And subscribe you can also
catch my show on Spotify Apple podcast
or wherever you get your podcast so go
check it out now I demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated